[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Таврія
Херсон]
Якщо я у вас запитаю:
з чим у вас асоціюється цирк?
Ви скажете: «З клоунами, слонами,
поганим запахом і так далі».
Ми працюємо у зовсім іншому напрямі.
У нас це вар'єте — цирковий театр,
це більш естрадний формат.
У нас у цирку немає тварин,
[Роман Ващенко
Керівник цирку Jin Roh]
ми обходимось людським ресурсом.
[сміється]
Ми — один із найбільших колективів в Україні.
Це близько 300 людей.
З них 180 дітей та
близько 120 дорослих артистів.
Ми звемось «Jin Roh».
Це означає суперсила.
Бо циркова діяльність — це, насамперед, те,
що потребує щоразу стрибати вище голови,
щоб дивувати глядача,
щоб вчити нові трюки тощо.
Засновник колективу — я.
Цього року ми святкуємо десятирічний ювілей.
Це те, навколо чого зараз побудоване моє життя.
Якщо в інших людей, наприклад, тренування,
і вони намагаються вписати їх
у свій життєвий графік,
то ми життя намагаємось
вписати у свій графік тренувань.
Це ж насправді велика спокуса —
в п'ятницю ввечері піти не на вечірку,
а на репетицію.
[сміється]
І формується той склад людей,
який готовий чимось жертвувати,
певними фрагментами свого життя.
Заради того, щоб прийти на репетицію
і потім вийти на сцену
і подарувати глядачу цей продукт,
віддати енергетику,
а взамін отримати енергетику глядача.
Ми всі трохи схиблені,
в хорошому сенсі цього слова.
Схиблені у творчому плані.
Ми намагались знайти способи, щоб тим,
що вміємо і чому присвятили все життя,
заробляти гроші.
Перше, що ми почали робити, — це фаєр-шоу,
робота з вогнем.
І якось так воно й пішло.
Потім до фаєр-шоу ми додали
хореографію, акробатику, трюки.
І це настільки розвинулось,
що поділилось на різні напрями.
Ми стали своєрідним автономним містом.
Ми самі собі шиємо костюми і
виготовляємо реквізит,
самі репетируємо, готуємо собі їсти.
Якщо у спорті чіткі рамки і вправи
можна виконувати тільки так,
то тут у нас політ фантазії і ми можемо розгулятися.
Придумати свої трюки та використовувати,
і ніхто нам не докорятиме — це великий плюс.
До нас на репетиції приїжджають з-за кордону.
Було 18 людей з Болгарії,
ми їм тут виставляли трюки.
Хореографи і режисери виставляли номери,
ми створювали ці номери.
Потім ці номери працювали по всьому світу.
Ми, мабуть, виграли в Україні всі фестивалі
і все, що можна було виграти у цирковому напрямі.
І, безумовно, саме там зароджувались
перші знайомства.
Десь з агентами, десь — з представниками іноземних театрів.
Історично так склалося,
що ми більш затребувані за кордоном.
Починаючи з азіатських країн, арабських країн
та закінчуючи Європою, Америкою,
Бразилією тощо.
В артистів на плечах українські прапори.
Усюди ми себе позиціонуємо
як український продукт.
І ми намагаємось, наприклад, коли англомовний
репертуар, беремо гурт The Hardkiss,
які мають якісний англомовний репертуар.
Щоб адаптувати українських виконавців там,
а не брати чергову Бейонсе.
Чого я хочу досягнути? Хороше питання, насправді.
Мабуть, працювати всередині своєї країни.
Бо цирковий світ розвинений
там більше, ніж у нас.
Мене це завжди дивує,
бо от ми живемо в країні,
заходиш зранку в маршрутку,
а навколо похмурі обличчя.
Ніхто одне з одним не привітається,
якось в нас це не прийнято.
А коли ми їдемо звідси, то сумуємо за цим.
І коли бачиш свого співвітчизника десь там —
ти його страшенно радий бачити.
Мене завжди дивувало питання:
чому цю радість не можна
показувати всередині своєї країни.
Чому не можна бути ближче одне до одного,
коли ми живемо тут.
Якби кожен намагався
зробити світ навколо себе кращим,
а нас, на хвильку, 40 мільйонів.
І ці 40 мільйонів маленьких двигунів,
які світ навколо себе робили б краще, —
то, я думаю, успіх нам гарантований.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Слобода]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Сценаристка
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Гапочка]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]